So this is the end of Unit 6.
Let me summarize what we've seen, and there are lots of connections
between the different things we've seen
that all use cryptography to solve problems.
So the first thing we looked at was Anonymous Communication,
and we saw how to do that using onion routing
which was a chain of public key encryptions.
We looked at how to do voting using mixes.
which also involved a chain of public key encryptions
with the addition of audited permutations.
We looked at how to provide
anonymous digital cash in a centralized way.
This involved using blind signatures.
But blind signatures pose the risk that if you don't know what you're signing
that's a big problem.
So we talked about the cut-and-choose technique
to verify the messages before signing the one that wasn't opened.
And finally we looked at bitcoin.
That provides a way to do decentralized digital cash.
This also used a chain of public keys
but unlike onion routing and voting, where we were using chains of encryptions,
in this case we are using chains of signatures.
And we also saw how bitcoin uses hash preimages as a proof of work.
And having proofs of work is useful for many other protocols,
So all these protocols use a combination of asymmetric cryptography
and symmetric cryptography typically involving hashing.
And there's a tremendous amount of things
that you can build with just these primatives.
In Unit 7, we'll look at a few more interesting applications of cryptography
and wrap up the course.
I hope to see you there.